this episode has been brought to you by
fast hosts find out more about them
later today we're gonna do hello world
on the Mega Drive following on from the
last video so this was a cross products
mega drive development kit with mega CD
kit built in from around 90 to 93 I use
this to create Tanglewood which is the
Sega Mega Drive that was released last
year and the whole thing was written in
68,000 assembly language using all my
own editor tools and things that I've
written to go with the engine so for the
past couple of videos we've been showing
very slowly how to get hello world on
the Mega Drive everything from
initializing the system to loading
pallets to it and today we're going to
show how to load graphic styles to it
and hopefully get some text on screen
doesn't have any kind of text-mode
system on it it doesn't have any
built-in fonts it doesn't run an
operating system nor does it have any
kind of standard library machine
comparable the time would have been the
Apple Macintosh which have had a printf
function would have had its own built-in
system fonts and stuff to do that the
mega drives got nothing when you switch
it on the memory is empty you have to do
everything yourself we have to design
our own font we have to upload those
font glyphs to the video memory we then
have to write our own text routines to
get text on the screen for now we're
just going to keep it simple we're going
to create a very basic font ourselves
we're going to show how to world on the
screen the Megadrive has a file based
graphics processor so it doesn't have a
bitmap system or a frame buffer you
can't draw lines or vectors on it
the screen is made up of tiles and in
this particular set of those 40 tiles
wide and 30 tiles high and each tile is
8 by 8 pixels wide with each entry in
that tile relating to a palette entry so
we've already uploaded the palette so
palette 0 is always transparent so we
ignore that so say we've got red green
and blue as colors 1 2 & 3 and the
palette to populate the tile we need to
put 1 1 1 1 for the top row of that tile
to be red the rest would be 0 which
would be transparency so I'll give us a
single horizontal line at the top this
should be 8 by 8 but can't draw very
well so to place this tile onto the
screen within each plane we have a grid
so we would have multiple tiles uploaded
to video memory we could reference
number 0 1 2 3 etc so for each of these
cells on the screen we would have 1 2
tile 7 there
and if we upload a blank tile first and
the rest would be zero and they would
show nothing so it's imagine that style
one relating to this tile on the screen
and that's color one relating to this
color in the palette and that's how the
graphics are made up on screen there are
two strolling planes on the Mega Drive
so we can have multiple tiles
overlapping each other we also scroll
those planes independently we could also
scroll each individual line of those
plates we can make wavy effects etc
there's also the sprite plane on top of
that and the window plane but we explain
those in a future video so in the
previous video we've already shown step
one which was how to upload the palette
so we've got a palette here 16 colors
just for the remind of the first one is
always transparency this is e e which is
white this is red green and the rest of
these are all black so that palette is
uploaded to video RAM using this macro
here set serum right so that sets up the
graphics processor to receive data at a
colorama address which we specify there
here we move 15 which is 16 minus 1
ready for the loop counter we set the
serum address we want to write 2 which
is 0 which is the first pallet we load
the pallet into an address register and
then we loop over each word in the
pallet and upload it to the VB big data
port we then use this command here to
set the background color to 2 which gave
us a red screen or orange screen on
YouTube so we're going to do something
very similar for the tiles first we need
to design our own tile so these tiles
are 32 bytes with each nibble that's a
half byte relating to a color in the
palette so we're going to have 8 pixels
for this top row and it's 8 pixels down
so 2
three four five six seven eight and
that'll give us a blank tile we can then
fill this in with the glyphs let's do an
X pattern just to show it off and each
one of these nipples relates to a color
number in the palette so who've got
transparencies there Oh white red green
blue so we're going to go from white
which is color one so for each of the
pixels we want to be white we fill in
one so it's a bit like ask your this
isn't it is yes very much like ASCII art
we're going to ignore the right hand
from the bottom hand column because
these tiles are adjacent to each other
so we want to gap in between okay so
there's our X pattern and we are going
to upload this to the first address in
vram that's where all the tiles are
stored
so we're going to need the set V RAM
right macro decide to address 0 but
before we do that I'm going to do some
more defined at the top here submit the
code easier to read we've got the size
of our palette in bytes words and long
so we're going to do the same again for
the tile the size of a tile in bytes is
32 bytes size of tile in words is size
tile bytes over 2 and size of tile in
Long's is size tile bytes over
four so that makes our code a little
easier to read so very similar to how we
uploaded the pallet here we're going to
move the size of the tile in long words
- one for the loop counter into register
d0 we're going to call our macro to set
the vram address so set vram right and
we're going to go for the very first
time on screen zero about the top left
then that would be the entire screen
because the whole screen is already
filled with zeros so they're all all
tiles on the screen it could be
referencing tile zero so if we upload
our exes tiles zero the whole screen is
gonna be full of X's and that's because
up here we've already cleared for you
Ram set me around white zero we've
looped through the whole of VRAM setting
it to zero so we're going to load our
tile into an address register 0 we're
gonna then create a loop tile right loop
and then for each long word in that tile
and increment the address every time
we're gonna write that to the VDP data
port and then decrement and branch our
loop character which is d0 back up to
the tile right loop if all goes well
that should give us a full screen full
of X tiles
so let's assemble that and then load up
in the debugger
so this is sending it to them yeah
sending it to the dev kits and using the
debugger to control the dev kit so we'll
load the binary we'll reset the C for
you now we have our source on screen the
executables loaded on to the debugger so
step one is to connect the debugger
write the TM s s signature which let's
just use the GPU we then load the
register table which sets up the GPU
here is where we clear the RAM here is
where we wrote the pallet in the last
video so just below this is our new code
where we're going to write the tiles so
if I set a breakpoint here and then run
that's now executing on the Megadrive
and we've already got up to this point
here when we stopped so if I step
through this one by one I could show you
what's going on so we move the size of
the tile that we're going to write in
long words minus one for the loop
counter into d0 so that's seven there
we're going to set the vram port to
receive address zero we're going to load
the address of our tile that we've just
written into address register a zero and
then for each long word in the tile
we're going to write it to the VDP data
port and then increment the address each
time and then loop until it's all
completed so I'm going to set another
breakpoint under to where that's
finished and then if I continue on that
should do all of that there we go so
there's our screen full of X tiles so
that's step one step two we're going to
need more than one style so we're gonna
need to design a font for this we will
leave the first tile blank which is a
bit wasteful because we've already
cleared hold of be around so the first
tiles already blank but this is a good
teaching tool to see so now we're going
to need glyphs for all of the text in
hello world so we're going to need H and
E and L and
aw and our and a date
let me just design all those font cliffs
so we're going to need an H in red this
is gonna take some considerable time
says our H there's our e there's an elf
you have to do this for Tanglewood then
did you have to design it would be fun I
did originally for the first system from
that I made just to show debugging info
on screen and that sort of stuff but
once I made my own graphics tool sets I
will manage to import all the fonts
there's our Oh
there's a 1 kW
[Applause]
how do you are
[Music]
there's an even one here are
[Applause]
[Music]
and the world's worst day
we Saturday probably Addie first find
out if it's Addie okay so there we have
our space and H and E and L and Oh a W
and R and a D so in order to reference
those tiles we can do some defines to
make this easier so if we have tile ID
space is tile zero file ID H is gonna be
one does that purely come down to what
order they appear in that list then yes
because we're going to upload those
consecutively each tile will be next to
each other in vram so you can then refer
to these by indices d-57 I'm also gonna
add the count so you can refer back to
it so it max tiles it's gonna be eight
throughout that help okay so now we need
to upload all of these tiles to be round
not just the first one so we've got a
count here max tiles so we're just going
to update our loop to update all eight
of them so size tile in lungs multiplied
by the number of tiles minus one for the
loop counter so if we assemble that and
run it we should now have a blank screen
again
because our first tile in memory is a
blank tile that we're going to be used
for the space so that's full of tile id0
and tile ID zero is completely blank so
the next step so as I explained before
we've got several planes on the Mega
Drive and a plane a beat plane we've
also got sprites and window planes as
well but we're going to ignore those for
now so in order to show one of these
tiles on screen we need to write to the
particular cell the tile ID that we want
to show at that cell so these planes
have their own addresses in vram if we
refer back to our vehicle registers
table which we wrote in the first video
you can see here we've got pattern table
to scroll plane a the window plane and
the be plane there and according to
these registers I've set this up an
address C zero zero zero so if we start
writing address to see zero zero zero
that would be the tile IDs for this
particular plane back here again we're
going to use our vram write macro again
so set the RAM rights and instead of
writing to zero we're now going to write
to see zero zero zero which the address
of plane a so all we need to do to show
one of these tiles at the start of plane
a which is zero zero in the top left
hand corner is to write the tile index
that we want to show file ID H to the
VDP data port so that will write the ID
of tile H to the start of plane a
and hopefully
so we reset the processor and if we run
that now there we go there's our H in
the top left-hand corner so we're most
of the way there now we just need to do
some copying and pasting so we don't
need to set the vram to write to the
next address every time because calling
to our VDP register table we've got the
auto increment register set to 2 bytes
so every time we write to the VDP is
going to automatically increment the
address by 2 bytes and each cell here is
2 bytes wide that's perfect for us so
let's copy that h-e-l-l-o space wo rld
again doing the space is a bit wasteful
because this space and the VDP data
should already be blank but instead of
recomputing the right address ready for
the w it's a lot quicker to just write
the space again w d so let's assemble
that
and fingers crossed I'll most any of
this up again
and there's the money shot with a wonky
our first house is a uk-based web
hosting company which offers a wide
range of web hosting products and other
services they aim to support UK
businesses and entrepreneurs at all
levels providing effective and
affordable hosting packages to suit any
need that virtual private service are
fast and give you access to affordable
VPS hosting with dedicated resources
including a hundred percent SSD storage
plus their data centers are in the UK
and you have the choice of Linux or
Windows operating systems if you want
you can have a dedicated server fast
hosts provide high performance hardware
that Intel Xeon processors and storage
options including superfast nvme SSDs
perfect for those demanding projects
they also offer cloud servers cloud
backup or bare metal solutions because
their data centers are based in the UK
alongside their offices whether you go
for a lightweight web hosting package or
a fully fledged dedicated box you can
talk to their expert support teams 24/7
find out more by following the link in
the description below